so okay level number one doesn't allow
that but now black has won a pawn as
well so a clear bishop up for nothing
yeah only has to deal against one threat
black's queen slides across
just controlling some light squares as
well there's a huge threat of black
bishop sneaking into the h3 square with
a check to the white king and okay we
see a trade of rooks that king will hide
on a dart square or maybe black will
block this with his bishop i think he
will just block it with a bishop and
okay aronian really trying to generate
something but it's a mission impossible
that porn
it looks it looks good but it's headed
nowhere and magnus is being ruthless we
have this kind of little motto okay we
have a result lavon aronian resigns
wow a great win for magnus carlsen and
the first game of today with the black
pieces as well taking the lead here in
the semi-final match against levon
aronian so that means aronian has to
make a comeback at some point today to
take it to tie breaks magnus logging off
quite fast here i live on roni and he
was sitting there